je sais pas si vous vous souvenez lors
de la conférence de lancement apple dans
l'acquis note à cuppertino du lancement
des iphone
11 on se prononce promax apple nous
avait montré une application vraiment
intéressante pour pouvoir filmer de
façon un petit peu révolutionnaire sera
smartphone une application fait pas
filmique filmique sais pas si vous
connaissez phoenix filmique prouve
qu'une application qui vous permet
d'optimiser complètement tout ce que
vous aller filmer avec votre smartphone
d'éditeurs un taux qui est vraiment
intéressant si vous connaissez pas
l'application en amical à télécharger et
à découvrir dans l'app store parce que
c'est vraiment une très très bonne
application pour tout ce qui va être
vidéo sur votre iphone et vous avez
effectivement dit qu'ils avaient un
partenariat avec filmique ou filmique
développé une application qui permettait
de choisir votre caméra en temps réel de
pouvoir choisir plusieurs caméras de
faire du multi caméras pour filmer en
même temps avec la caméra de celle qui
est en même temps avec la caméra arrière
pouvoir faire effectivement des
interviews vous posez votre iphone vous
filmez vous filmez votre talent octobre
côté en photo qui était vraiment
intéressant et c'est une belle promesse
alors cette application on l'attendait
en face surtout moi j'imagine beaucoup
de personne qui filme avec des iphone et
qu'ils disent ok on a vraiment envie
d'aller beaucoup plus loin en terme de
vidéo de l'iphone et justement ça y est
elle est enfin arrivée donc ça c'est
cool l'application s'appelle double-take
vous pouvez la télécharger sur l'app
store bien évidemment ce n'est pas la
même application filmique pro est une
autre application à venir télécharger
c'est une application gratuite donc ça
c'est vachement cool qui vous permet
effectivement de filmer avec votre
iphone et ce à différentes manières vous
le film aurait pas ici en 4k on va
pouvoir filmer en full hd
j'imagine que lorsque les iphone de nous
rendre plus en puissance ils permettront
d'aller encore plus loin on pourra
filmer en cas de cas là dessus pour
l'instant vous ferez du full hd ce qui
est plutôt pas mal pour venir partager
sur instagram tik tok facebook consorts
et compagnie et même pourquoi pas des
vidéos sur youtube
donc ça ça marche je montre comment ça
marche parce que tout est vraiment
vraiment vraiment super ce qu'il faut
que vous fassiez vous avez dans votre
iphone et vous allez dans votre
application d'apple tech tac vous
l'ouvrez alors moi j'utilise depuis
quelques temps un iphone 11 promax en
usage personnel parce que c'est un des
rares smartphones qui est vraiment bon
en terme de vidéo il ya l'autre point
sur lequel apple est excellent il
progresse toujours plus et sur la vidéo
la qualité et je la trouve vraiment très
très juste
lo'jo écoule capte plus que bien l'auto
surtout c'est la stabilisation vous avez
une stabilisation qui est complètement
incroyable sur la caméra rien c'est
extrêmement bien mais
crise et c'est vraiment temps que ça ne
bouge absolument pas il ya un autre truc
qui est vraiment bien vivre l'expérience
c'est que lorsque vous vous avez filmé
comme ça avec votre à venir zoomer
dézoomer directement vous gardez la
stabilisation dans ce secteur à des jeux
lire zoom et je crois gauche sur la
voiture de police avec le zoom numérique
à tout ça part bien du numérique
j'ai regardé la stabilisation est
incroyable il ya beaucoup de smartphones
qui sont vraiment excellents en termes
de photos beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup son
droid mais en terme de vidéo qu'elle a
quelques-uns des très peu et justement
pour moi l'iphone on se promet max c'est
un des meilleurs smartphones en vidéo il
faut se le dire donc si vous voulez
vraiment faire de la vidéo je vous
invite à aller sur ce smartphone lac est
vraiment bien et notamment pour tout ce
qui va être story instagram avec
beaucoup de smartphones sur android vous
allez voir de la storia ce programme qui
va être complètement optimisé en termes
de qualité lorsque vous à l'exporter eh
bien ça va venir compris ça va pas être
terrible
du côté de samsung avec les modèles de
la dernière s 10 et 9 10 vous allez
pouvoir effectivement aller plus loin
puisqu'ils ont intégré une fonction
était directement partenariat bhl des
power exporté depuis votre application
caméra directement sur instagram donc ça
va beaucoup moins compressé vous aurez
meilleure qualité vous avez exactement
la même chose en terme de qualité là
dessus avec les iphone donc ça il faut
le savoir et si vous faites de la vidéo
ça c'est vraiment très très important
donc quand vous avez ouvert vous arrivez
directement l'aide sud vous voyez ça
alors vous pouvez utiliser à la
verticale vous pouvez effectivement
l'utiliser à l'horizontale sa tombe sans
aucun problème là pour l'instant on va
l'utiliser à l'horizontale vous avez en
haut à gauche une petite icône qui vous
montrent effectivement tout vol stockage
en bas à gauche et c'est là que ça
devient très intéressant vous allez
choisir directement que vous allez
pouvoir filmer vous avez donc la partie
wild c'est le capteur principal c'est le
fib on vous devine dresser la caméra de
celle fille ultra wide celle ultra
grand-angle et ensuite vous avez le thé
les photos le téléobjectif et pour venir
filmer directement près donc vous
sélectionnez ce que vous voulez non on
va se faire un petit wide est un petit
selphy une fois que vous avez fait ça
vous confirmez
au milieu il a d'ailleurs plusieurs
modes pour venir filmer vous allez
choisir maintenant l'icône en haut à
droite soit un écran divisé
c'est à dire votre écran va vraiment
venir partager sur la partie de gauche
j'ai ma caméra principale sur la partie
droite j'ai ma caméra de celle ci et là
je vais enregistrer les deux directement
même temps qu en europe
je me fais un enregistrement l'âge
enregistre les deux directement même
temps alors la caméra arrière et
stabiliser la caméra nom n'est pas
stabilisée on sent la différence surtout
moi lorsque je veux te dire comme ça ça
c'est une partie principale hop on
arrête enregistrements je peux faire
exactement le même exercice à la
verticale je prends tac
j'enregistre donc là en bas âge et ma
caméra tête fille en haut j'ai ma caméra
principale tout ça ça nous enregistrons
seul et même fichier donc là on partage
effectivement l'écran droite gauche haut
bas
ensuite je reviens cliquer et là j'ai
séparé en fait ce que je vois c'est une
incrustation de la caméra de celle fille
en bas et ensuite devant la caméra
principale on en fait ce qui se passe
ici c'est juste une incrustation au
terme de monitoring pour pouvoir le voir
mais ça vous créé deux fichiers séparés
donc la tac je vais enregistrer c'est
donc ma caméra principale où je vois
lâche en train de filmer de l'autre côté
la police passe nos mains safin ici et
ensuite je me suis ici moi de l'autre
côté alors je peux venir passer en grand
si j'ai besoin de voir au tac j'ai la
grandit devant un peu plus grand de ce
côté là je peux le faire pour plus de
confort mais en fait il faut savoir que
sont réellement deux fichiers séparés à
l'enregistrement
donc ça c'est plutôt bien ensuite je re
cliquer là dessus et j'ai image dans
l'image à leur image dans l'image
lorsque je le regarde comme ça d'un
point de vue purement monitoring j'ai
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire
que je vois ma petite caméra qui est
superposé sauf qu'en fait ça me créer un
seul fichier avec l'incrustation et
c'est pas mal aussi
donc là c'est pareil tac je viens
enregistré j'ai donc ma caméra ici je
suis moi ici à l'avant je peux venir
bouger mon incrustation sauf que là
c'est vraiment mieux bouger directement
dans ma vidéo lorsque j'enregistre oui
jamais vraiment où je veux aux cendres
sur les côtés sur une espèce de cadres
en fait je veux pas la place et
n'importe comment elle se positionner
c'est bien je peux venir l'agrandir et
je peux venir ensuite la réduire je peux
venir appui à droite à gauche
conservant une exposition photo qui est
relativement simple ça marche bien c'est
pratique hélas malgré tout dans un seul
et même fichier
donc ça c'est vachement bien bien
évidemment à l'horizontale mais
également alors pas la verticale parce
qu'il faut que j'arrête tac je stoppe
une fois que j'ai stoppé
je tourne ça tourne et je peux venir
enregistrer up exactement la même
manière ici à la verticale où je vois
mon incrustation je peux dépasser enfin
vous avez compris le truc c'est vraiment
la même chose donc on a fait le tour
écran divisé on a ensuite l'écran
séparés et on a ensuite l'image dans
l'image on faisait pas écran séparé sans
registre de fichiers c'est paris donc ça
c'est bien je peux recliquer ensuite en
bas à gauche et là je peux changer le
dire allez hop je me prends un
téléobjectif et je me prends mon
ultra-grand-angle tac je confirme au
milieu et voyez j'ai mes deux fichiers
comme ça alors ça fait pas mal lorsque
venir filmer des bâtiments à l'extérieur
et lorsque tu act up j'enregistre parce
que je veux dire fais allumer des
bâtiments montré un plan là je montre un
temps un peu plus serré bon pourquoi pas
en fait ce qui est bien et ce qui est
génial avec ça c'est qu'on va
effectivement ça vient booster votre
créativité c'est un outil qui est
vraiment là pour la créativité
alors il a effectivement plusieurs
intérêts lorsque vous filmez vous que
vous êtes par exemple dans la rue en
mode reportage vous dit bah tiens
regarde et je me bats à tel endroit et
que vous voulez qu'on vous voit en même
temps et vous voulez qu'on voit en même
temps ce que vous allez en train de
filmer tiens je me fais ça en ultra
grand angle là par exemple voyez je peux
le faire un mode reportage regardait le
superbe bâtiment vous en face mans c'est
un superbe bâtiment
regardez le superbe bâtiment que vous
avez en face il ya cia sage peut
regarder en haut je peux regarder en bas
c'est pratique regarder la moto c'est
super bien en même temps on vous voit
vous directement vous adresser donc ça
crie quelque chose d'extrêmement
intéressant donc ça c'est bien que
faites vous sur la même chose vous
mettez deux trois intervenants en face
de vous vous mettez vous faites une
interview et vous pouvez soit tout à
voir dans le seul et même fichier en
vous disant ok je fais tout dans un seul
et même fichier auquel cas bien on me
voit moins en incrustation et on les
voit en eux en même temps ça peut être
assez rigolo alors pourquoi pas forcé
deux fichiers séparés comme ça fait une
conversation pourrait passer d'un plan à
un plan b extrêmement facilement donc à
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
imaginer et je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment bien
alors là je vous montre effectivement
cette façon là mais vous pouvez allez
encore un peu plus loin vous cliquez en
bas à gauche et là vous vous retrouvez
ici pour regarder en bas à droite vous
avez un chiffre 25 frames par seconde on
vous pouvez choisir votre framerate
votre nombre d'image par seconde
25 images par secondes 30 images par
secondes 24 images par seconde
bon vous allez pas à monter jusqu'à 60
images par secondes je pense une fois
puissant en termes de performance par
rapport aux smartphones vous voyez ces
petites applications c'est très simple
très intuitif et si vous regardez en bas
à gauche vous avez le petit icône
filmique qui vous permet de switcher hop
là directement dans clinique ensuite
vous pouvoir apporter vos fichiers
pouvoir faire ce que vous voulez dans le
truc est vachement bien beau film x est
une autre application
je vais pas vous faire un reboot
filmique aujourd'hui mais en tout cas je
trouve ça vachement cool en va de notre
application d'apple tech et lorsque vous
êtes là en haut à gauche
vous allez pouvoir retrouver tous vos
fichiers vous allez pouvoir exporter
très très facilement alors vous les
voyez on l'a effectivement j'ai les
fichiers j'ai les dates je vois le temps
que ça dure et jon c'est du 1080p
je vois le poids du fichier je vois le
nombre d'image par seconde
enfin le truc qui écoulent leurs engrais
que j'ai effectivement c'est le film
comme je vous disais uniquement en full
hd peut pas filmer en 4k on peut pas
tout avoir en tout cas pour l'instant ça
fonctionne comme ça je peux choisir
chier je peux venir le visionner
directement bon c'est très facile
ensuite peut venir sélectionner un
fichier ou deux fichiers de j'en ai
sélectionné deux je peux venir
l'enregistrer dans les vidéos je peux
les partager je peux et tagué je peux
envoyer des amis enfin je serais même
pas mal pas mal de choses donc le truc
est vachement bien en termes de
production et de productivité je trouve
ça vraiment cool voilà peu pour le tour
cette application pour le test pour vous
montrer un petit peu comment ça marche
d'abate pareil filmique je trouve ça moi
vraiment intéressant je testerai
davantage ce soit sur tik tok ce soit
sur instagram
je serai davantage de choses comme ça ça
permettra effectivement de voir et de
booster sa créativité pourquoi pas
l'intégrer lorsque j'allais faire des
plans extérieurs ont pas avoir tout ça
tout ça tout ça voilà dites moi ce que
vous en pensez à ce que c'est une
application qui pourrait vous vous
intéressez est ce que vous voyez
l'intérêt ce que ça vous tente
oui non pas comment vous marquez tout ça
en bas en commentaire quant à nous on
retrouve demain bien évidemment pour
continuer à parler texte cette
application bien évidemment n'est que
sur iphone donc si vous voulez utiliser
il vous faut un iphone compatible ce que
ce à partir de l'iphone dit c'est ce que
je dise pas de bêtise crasse et bien
parce que ça booste vraiment la
créativité
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire à catane où on se
retrouve demain pour côté du à parler
paix de l'amour demain djaouga
[Musique]